un politique encore avec une victoire
très étriqué pour le successeur désigné
de serge dassault à corbeil essonnes
jean pierre bechter n'a remporté les
municipales qu'avec un écart de 27 voix
mais ce qui est plutôt étonnant c'est
qu'il a déjà annoncé qu'il laisserait le
bureau du maire à serge dassault même si
ce dernier est inéligible il gardera
donc la main sur la commune valérie
astruc bruno vignais
la bise aux vrais vainqueurs
malgré la présence du candidat élu c'est
sur le nom de serge dassault que ces
jouets l'élection
mon vote populaire qui on a confiance et
m'ont fait confiance un peu plus qu'à
l'autre tant pis si comme ça mais ça
prouve quand même que les gens janquin
sans doute que les épaules
inéligible pendant un an le milliardaire
n'aura pas l'écharpé de maire mais
gardera les commandes de la ville je
tiens le dire je leur installerait dans
son bureau de maire jean perrault à côté
pour la ligue les élections se sont
déroulées tout à fait normalement et
quand le représentant du préfet proclame
les résultats la tension monte dans la
mairie
qu'est ce qui a fonctionné lors de ce
second tour le système serge dassault et
le candidat communiste d'appeler les
habitants à signaler pour les
irrégularités qu'ils auraient pu
observer c'est difficile de combattre
assystem qui distribue des 1000 et 2000
et 3000 des 4000 euros quand new labour
a opposé des idées des valeurs et un
projet face au faible écart de voix la
liste de gauche envisagerait un recours
devant le conseil d'état le feuilleton
corbeil essonnes n'est peut-être pas
terminée folie